The Android 5.0 introduced
a new tool bar widget.
This generalization of the action bar
pattern, gives you much more control and
flexibility.
Tool bars of view and your hierarchy
just like any other, making it easier to
interweave with the rest of your hues,
animate and react to scroll events.
Many Androids apps now have two or
more tool bars.
As in this example.
Toolbars are made particularly
important, because of the design rule
that we aren't supposed to split a
toolbar with another piece of material.
This means we often
need multiple toolbars.
Fortunately, we have a fully
functional version that has been
built as part of the Android
support library.
In order to make use of toolbar, we need
to first change our application to use
a theme that doesn't add
an action bar on our behalf.
I'm going to create a base toolbar
style, that gives it a background color.
Toolbars have transparent
backgrounds by default.
We'll also make sure that we're
using the light pop up theme.
This will be important when
you set the toolbars to
the dark theme in our layouts.
That we can have a little more light
colored text that will pop against our
dark background.
I can make all of my
toolbars get this new style,
by placing a toolbar
style in the app theme.
Then you just add
the toolbar into our layout.
Note that I'm setting the size to
be the standard action bar size
from the current theme,
using the ?attr notation.
And I'm setting the theme to
be the overlay theme for dark.
This will nicely style
us with light text.
Finally, I can make the toolbar
behave like an action bar.
By setting into the activity
using setSupportActionBar.
Once it's there, I can apply action bar
styling to it using getSupportActionBar.
I could use these functions
to get the icon back, but
I want to demonstrate one other
cool thing about toolbar.
It contains a view group
that you can customize.
This view group is like an even
more simple frame layout.
So we could add our logo back
to the toolbar this way.
This level of control,
becomes useful as we continue
to work towards our new design.